yassine belattar taille tout bon des
bois de liesse il est parti vous faites
les missions durent de plus en plus
longtemps ça va mon choix je suis
déprimé avec les audiences d'hier soir à
la finale à franges et j'en ai passé à
21h15 n'avait d endurance avec budapest
soir vont faire quoi après font pas
toujours les pins ils ne font pas chier
ça coûtera moins cher
bonsoir bonsoir tout le bon sens est ce
que le micro marche
voilà seulement parce que hier cyril là
j'en connais ta proximité avec la france
profonde
tpm paix passés de ses huit à radio
sochaux on salue sochaux en 2011
alors attendez attendez il paraît qu'il
ya que moi qui ai un micro pour
l'instant tout a sauté ya que moi qui
peut parler donc voilà donc ces voix là
bas c'est ça ccc ccc pour ça c'est pour
ça qu'ont donc oui comme par hasard à ba
écoute je vais donner mon avis non mais
alors à lévis il voulait parler et il
n'y a que mon micro qui marchent pas de
me plonger dans l'émission pour tous les
techniciens sauf pour cyril comme par
hasard ça qu'on flou il ya déjà des
théories qui circule sur internet du
coup mon cyril tu t'es dit je suis
affûté aujourd'hui normal il a fait de
l'endurance hier pendant 10 minutes
[Musique]
donc il est prêt pour paris 2024 il
représentera le ba-ba ce temps
formidable on envoie ce tous les
techniciens sont qui ont été d'ailleurs
merci
la plupart ont été virés ce matin en
réunion
non jamais jamais la grosse affaire
d'hier ce sont les dîners clandestins
oui on va reparler soit je sais qu'elle
peut procurer une quarantaine de
convives sans masquer certains se font
la bise si les visages sont floutés les
voit transformé la journaliste précise
que l'organisateur est un célèbre
collectionneur
ce collectionneur mono mais se défend et
dénonce une pratique généralisée très
vite des internautes pensent savoir de
qui il s'agit et cite le nom de pierre
jean chalencon sur les réseaux après
plusieurs heures de silence par le biais
de son avocat monsieur chalencon a
reconnu être la personne interviewée
dans le reportage de m6 alors dans les
clandestins s'étaient les immigrés
maintenance et les dîners la différence
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup moins d'arabes
et de noirs
mais je soupçonne des gens aisés de
vouloir se mettre dans la peau d'un
clandestin pour voir ce que ça fait en
tout cas pierre-jean chalands sont tous
là câble dans le reportage mais lui
droit dans ses bottes sets jeudi
nous étions quelques cassettes des cas
si la veille à vnf cassel se batturent
adn et sur l'ensemble de la soirée qui
se termine et 22e et commencé à 17 ans
que je fais à 17h30 au kenya a été on
avait dressé des tables c'était
uniquement pour la présentation que le
puissant thor dame est appelé j'étais de
cuisine depuis quelques mois dans ce cas
comment j'aurais pu faire des choix et
je suis quelqu'un de gentil généreux et
quand j'invite les gens à dîner chez moi
c'est moi qui les invitent ce que dans
mon cas parler de moi en bien ou en mal
mais parlez de moi est à deux doigts
dire regardez ça c'est mes factures des
livres ou et arrivent ivres et une cape
fromage et un coca zéro
à part ça on a quand même deux enfants
le mec il fait des dînes à 17h30 c'est
vrai ça s'appelle un goûter mais c'est
pas grave
et deux enfants monsieur charles ans on
sursaute qui est son vrai nom dirait le
nom d'une ville ou d'un vin par exemple
peut dire c'est un chaland son départ le
bicentenaire de napoléon avait alors
qu'est ce qu'on s'en bat vraiment du
bicentenaire de napoléon à par stéphane
bern et lorànt deutsch qui va acheter
les droits
alors ce soir sur canal+
ne ratez pas l'évènement du week end le
bicentenaire de napoléon
revivez la création du concordat et
surtout la rédaction du code civil avec
les stars de l'époque jean jacques régis
de cambacérès et charles françois lebrun
et en bouquet final
ne ratez pas le match austerlitz passe à
waterloo avec nous à perdre en chalencon
en fait sa douleur est là il va encore
rebondi en ce qu'il ya encore des choses
qui aideront à rhinau journée évidemment
alors je voulais quand même revenir sur
mon chouchou mon cher civile l'homme qui
tient un niveau quand même de
maladresses télévisuelle quotidien mais
c'est pas facile de tenir ce rythme ces
gens mais si à bas israël peut que
tailleur pour dames en les deux habitent
dans nos studios
là je m'excuse auprès des
téléspectateurs parce que je suis un
vieux responsable avec cyril de la
création de ce monstre je me sens dans
la peau du docteur frankenstein qu ai-je
ans il a encore parlé de moi la semaine
dernière que j'étais pas là il parle
tout le temps de moins et c'était ici
face à bernard montiel jeu
en fait je ne suis jamais autant
animalisés que par les progressistes
comme vous vous avez votre ami bela tarr
qui l'avait traité de chameau vous vous
nous réservez vous me traitez de rats ça
pose pas de problème alors c'est vrai
que berlin moi je t'aime beaucoup mais
il faut qu'on se mettre d'accord sur un
animal tous les animaux perso je trouve
qu'il ressemble à un chameau et hier sur
twitter il a réagi à l'agression de
bernard tapie il a dit ça on va revoir
le tweet de jean médiation là bien sûr
les agresseurs de mer à tapis sont
quatre dont trois africains et un de
type nord-africain le même bernard tapie
qui accusait jean marie le pen ce
mensonge sur le lien entre insécurité
invasion battoir il est aujourd'hui
rattrapé par la réalité bon état buchon
à la il est là mon champions lionel
messi on peut encore tout dire en france
et jean mais s'il a acquis une telle
notoriété que je suis tombé sur ce
sondage c'est pas une blague
regardez le meilleur candidat de la
droite dans ses rangs de l'extrême
droite en 2022 devant marine le pen
serait enjambées
alors vous dites qu'ils diffusent ce
sondage et bien c'est un organisme très
sérieux regarder au terme des gones n'a
pas vu sa mauléon c'est vrai nom c'est
moi l'argent mais si un comme ce sera
avec nous tout à l'heure le diamant on
embrasse prend soin de toi mon fils
c'est ici que tu es né et j'espère que
pour une fois y aura une panne de micro
merci la cible et la taverne chez moi si